you're engaged I mean yes I mean you're
set to be married and it's been so
incredible seeing your love story with
Nadia kind of bloom and blossom on
social media you actually told me I
think when you first started dating
maybe like a year and a half ago that
you had found someone and you were
totally in love so let me just say I am
a spending Christmas in love this year
you know how I like to travel
we met traveling and she's from overseas
and so she's adventurous and has all
that it's gonna adventurous spirit like
you do that's exactly what and
fast-forward to October of 2019 you pop
the question I want to know how is
engage life going it's so good I mean we
just we just did a great trip together
I actually missed out on a couple of
episodes of the rookie while we were
traveling I didn't want to leave Nadia
in Bali by herself and we're just loving
life together
we're wedding planning now as well which
I thought was gonna be a nightmare
by the way well what has been your
experience so far love wedding planning
Dan oh no I'm telling you it is so much
fun
what are you enjoying most just creep I
think it's the creative process of it
okay so know you're actually involved
yeah Wow okay cuz a lot of guys at least
like guys and like in my social circle
are kind of like we're gonna let the
bride take the lead you can choose
whatever she wants yeah he's the boss
okay
she's the final decision of course she
is I just present her with the options
yeah or she'll present me with the
options we'll discuss but the final say
is Nadia it's her special day she's you
know princess for for her wedding oh
it's true Queen yes yes but you're
enjoying the planning process I mean
where are you guys at with that right
now have you set a date we've set a date
you have it's gonna be at the end of
summer okay and it's gonna be in a
tropical location I'll just say that oh
okay well I'm just gonna put some ideas
out there we're actually keeping it
secret as well not the country but the
actual
because we're keeping it secret from
even our guests they don't know where
it's gonna be we've got special
transportation for them to get there so
you're gonna tell your guests the
country they need to go to and we just
told them we just told them yeah yeah
because people gotta book flight so it's
not Hawaii cuz that's in the United
States uh-huh oh I'm trying to think of
where it could be I mean you've done a
lot of traveling is it somewhere you
guys have been before as a matter of
fact it is well you just brought up Bali
could it be Bali it could be okay
no is it Paulie I just said you're good
oh that's so beautiful what was it that
sold you on Bali look the people are
fantastic the climate is fantastic it's
an energy in the air they're like great
smells amazing food like if you're a
foodie go to Bali mmm like it's
surprisingly surprisingly great well
that's important at a wedding yes okay
so I'm gonna run down a list of a few
wedding questions okay and hopefully you
can give me some answers here uh-huh
what will be on the menu there is going
to be very good patch burgers no I just
made that that'd be so good are you
really transporting from Sacramento Wow
we thought we can have Western food
anywhere you only get gonna get like one
chance to really enjoy Balinese cuisine
yes the true authentic excellent and
that's in Bali yeah you know and so we
thought maybe we'll go down that road
okay I like that idea yeah keep it
authentic what is your ideal guest list
count have you already established that
you said you have been notified I think
we'd want a very small handful of people
but you can't do that you know like
family everybody wants to celebrate you
that's right you know and so you there
are people that you have to invite sorry
family you know I love you
so like 30 50 yeah we're gonna have
about around about 80 guests you know so
you got got quite a a big family and
obviously a few friends but it's hard
because you know through my life and
through Nadia's life we've acquired many
many friends many people so to get 80
people to Bali is truly very impressive
that means people really love you guys I
want to celebrate your love story we
sent out the invitation and we were
shocked at how many people replied
within 24 hours that they were
definitely coming you know and that Dan
Nadia Bali those are like three
absolutely filled Oh hot so you know oh
that's so nice that people want to
celebrate us so special what kind of
cake like a flavor or a design sure so
are you guys not cake people a lot of
people are now doing cake pops ice cream
whatever you enjoy right so we've got a
few different dessert items but there's
definitely gonna be a cake and I'm a
chocolate guy Yeah right
I love my chocolate hmm Nadi is not as
into chocolate as I am but we've come to
a compromise so we actually haven't
we've got an idea with the cake but we
haven't like looked looked in everything
yet okay what about music or
entertainment great is there a chance
you would perform there's a chance yeah
there's probably a good chance have you
written Nadia a love song oh maybe maybe
I've started writing sorry god I'm gonna
start crying already
I'm such a sad secret Nadia don't watch
[Laughter]
I mean have you have you really been
like playing around with your guitar
writing lyrics of course how do you put
into lyrics what she means to you yeah
good question it's hard you don't want
to get up there and in front of you all
your friends and family and like you're
so great I love you but you do want to
go out there and well you know when
you're writing a song anyways what I did
four years before I was acting and was
write music and play music around Sydney
right this is your wheelhouse yeah yeah
and so I want to write a song that's
like a you know a catchy tune that she
can sing afterwards that she'll remember
it's it's something that I'm I've just
started Wow that is the ultimate special
wedding gift I mean in addition to a
performance from you will you have a DJ
a band yes I'm really I'm lucky to know
some of Australia's best musicians yeah
so we're gonna we're gonna set up some
live music early on and then we've got a
DJ without playing all our favourite
songs oh my gosh so is this gonna be a
real rager on the beach are you going
for a hard party here uh you know no
Australian I know you like to have a
good time yes well you wouldn't have a
great time yeah yeah we're gonna have a
great time what would you describe the
wedding as is it gonna be Beach casual
are you asking your guests to come in
formal wear we actually haven't talked
about the dress code yet I think it all
depends on Nadia's dress and wish sort
of she's her dress that's the tone yes
and then we'll as as the date gets
closer other months get closer will
inform our guests of what we're what
we're after you're you're obviously very
close with Nadia you know her taste
backwards and forwards what kind of
dress do you think she's gonna wear we
share everything and it's really hard
for her not to go what do you think good
this one right you know and I just told
her there's one thing that I do not want
to know I don't want to be involved with
it keep me out of it and that's the
wedding dress because the first time I
see her I want to see her walking down
the aisle towards me
and that's that I'm gonna lose it you
think so I know so your eyes are getting
a little teary here well I love the I
love the woman but that's one of those
that's a special that's one of those
moments that you don't ever forget and
and I think that being able to see your
fiancee
becoming your wife seeing her for the
first time in in a dress that she loves
it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty
special I'm trying to leave expectations
out of it I'm just gonna try and be in
the moment you know but it's I think I
might have even told you this before
movies sometimes songs they just get
yeah totally for your vows are you gonna
write your own vows or do you think
you'll go traditional and use the old
school no I think we'll do our own yeah
yeah I think so although she's she's
like hesitant with that why whoa she's
kind of got this wicked sense of humor
you know and I you can infuse that into
her I think so as well I think that's I
think that's really really cute you know
I saw uh look at the end of the day it's
gonna be up to her whatever she wants to
do who do you think is gonna cry more
and who will cry first I'm gonna cry
more and first and last just be a big
pile of tears all day oh yeah tears of
joy me you know I love that and I mean
have you had conversations about wanting
a family and and expanding the family
yeah yeah yeah of course I don't think
that I would have asked this woman to
marry me if I couldn't envision us
having children together do you have
like a timeline on that or when you see
what happening
she might okay Wow little listings
running around I love that can we expect
any of your former when calls the heart
stars to be at your wedding hopefully
they can in fact you can expect one
because we've got one confirmation so
far
can you tell us how yeah Martin Cummings
Martin coming is coming to volley yeah
he's coming Wow good but we're waiting
on we've sent out other invitations okay
and we'll we'll wait for responses we
know at that time people could be
shooting sure you know yeah there could
be stuff going on well you know we sent
out some invitations and we'll see so
you you are still very close you still
invited your cast mates from one calls
the heart to your wedding right not
everyone but you know certainly people
that very close to can you share a few
names well Aaron of course of course
Aaron I've been I know you just as much
as Nadia appreciate a fashion-forward
moment have you started looking at what
you're gonna wear
first and foremost it's about Nadia's
dress and the vibe of that dress and
your marriage it yeah yeah that's right
but you know we're gonna be in a pretty
hot location I don't want to be all
buttoned up you know fixing on your
wedding day
let's see on the wedding day boy guv all
pretty good Yiddish well I'm Jewish man
so I you know grew up with my with my
you know family they originally from
Holland right at the Jewish side of the
family and my Uncle Sam was like I got
the biggest pool in the neighborhood but
you never come around he literally
talked like that he was like you know
Uncle Sam
[Music]